[Musique]
[Rires]
très vite
je l'embrasse un maire offre des
doudouses à ses élèves pour supporter la
baisse de chauffage utile honteux pensez
quoi cette décision fille malgré ce
qu'on avait parce que pendant des
adultes de faire des efforts je peux
encore le concevoir mais des enfants ou
les personnes âgées on n'a pas leur
imposé une température trop froide et
physiquement ils sont quand même moins
résistants bien sûr il y en a deux bien
portant donc c'est quoi ça c'est
absolument scandaleux et c'est pas une
polaire qui va changer les choses quand
on est en classe on bouge pas donc bien
sûr même une polémique
mais qui sait que cette histoire non
mais comment on peut faire alors vous
vous dites NON vous je peux plus vous
blairer
non c'est pas c'est pas aux enfants de
subir ça en fait il laisse la salle
comme elle est chauffée comme d'hab
comme a toujours fait on dit pas qu'il
faut la mettre à 24 on dit qu'on la
laisse à peut-être à 19 20 ou 21 il y a
pas offrir des polaires en fait touche
pas au chauffage c'est à dire quoi comme
il dit il passe montagne je suis sûr de
ski combinaison de ski les enfants ils
vont aller en récré ils vont courir ils
vont rentrer en transpiration on leur
met des polaires dessus c'est n'importe
quoi je trouve ça complètement débile
non non mais je trouve ça complètement
débile vraiment votre message sinon
enchanté mais je trouve ça complètement
débile comme comme mesure c'est une
mesure à la con voilà non mais c'est
n'importe quoi
laissez-moi avoir un argument s'il vous
plaît c'est que dans tous les cas la
classe ça sera pas en dessous de 19
parce que ça c'est pas légal on va pas
les mettre à 10 degrés donc si le prof
il décide le maire il décide de leur
offrir une doudoune à chacun c'est
toujours ça de prix c'est tous les mers
décidé d'offrir des manteaux à tous les
enfants de France
en faisant ça il laisse entendre en
faisant Mathieu Mathieu non parce qu'en
faisant ça ce geste il laisse entendre
qu'il est d'accord avec la décision
c'est ça ce qui va pas exactement ça
ne changera pas le faire justement
tu peux les mettre ailleurs les sous
pour s'aperçu
que j'adore en ce moment non c'est
ridicule c'est honteux et puis il y a
une manipulation dans la présentation de
la formation c'est-à-dire qu'on nous
fait croire que la bonne nouvelle c'est
que les élèves recevoir des colères les
parents de la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
qu'on met leur santé en danger en les
exposant froid toute la journée j'ai
regagné le gang des suceurs là oui si
mais j'ai changé pour vous non mais
suceurs et c'est tout à fait encore une
fois ça me fait mal au cœur que des
Français qui n'y peuvent rien pèsent une
mauvaise gestion d'un conflit
géopolitique on aurait peut-être pu
éviter et que ce soit les enfants qui
payent c'est honteux voilà bravo je suis
complètement d'accord d'accord
avec Kelly je trouve que Kelly a
vraiment totalement raison Kelly
Vedovelli c'est bon c'est le bon sens en
fait Kenny et en fait non alors
évidemment c'est un gadget évidemment
c'est de la pomme évidemment c'est du
marketing politique mais je trouve que
c'est pas très très grave en fait c'est
pas la peine d'en faire une sorte de
scandale là vous jouez les offusqués je
vous rappelle que les mêmes non je parle
évidemment pas de vous aussi de Mathieu
donc je me souviens que pendant la crise
du covid les mêmes disaient oh mais
alors pourquoi on peut pas ouvrir les
fenêtres des classes pour aérer c'est
pas grave si c'est possible
on s'en fout on les couvrir ah il est
comme ça il y aura pas de problème il y
aura pas de différence
et on va travailler si c'est on peut
ouvrir les fenêtres en cas extrême tu
vois une fois d'accord tu prends un café
on défendre un maire qui va dépenser
5000 balles à la poubelle il y a pas de
problème dans sa vie il y a pas il y a
pas de problème dans sa vie administrées
d'accord
est-ce que la situation est aussi
dramatique que ça oui parce que là avec
avec l'arrêt du gaz c'est quand même une
énergie qui est importante en France sur
la totalité de l'énergie consommée en
France le gars ça représente 15%. bon il
faut savoir qu'en Allemagne c'est 27 %
parce que eux ils ont beaucoup moins
centrales nucléaires je suis en train de
gaz alors surtout ce gaz il y a une
partie qui vient de la Russie qui marque
maintenant c'est coupé il y a une partie
qui vient ailleurs on peut un peu
compenser mais le problème ça va
dépendre est-ce que le parc nucléaire va
se remettre à fonctionner en totalité ça
c'est prévu mais c'est pas sûr et puis
le problème aussi c'est que si l'hiver
est très rigoureux ça va dépendre de la
météo on risque d'avoir des problèmes
pour les gens qui pourront les gens qui
sont au gaz qui vous empêche de chauffer
et il y a aussi le problème aussi pour
les entreprises est-ce que l'hiver va
être rude pour tout le monde oui ça
risque parce que en fonction de
justement des températures si l'hiver
est très rigoureux on peut avoir
carrément on peut manquer de gaz à ce
moment-là tous les établissements
chauffés au gaz si c'est le cas de cette
école par exemple ça a pas chauffer du
tout donc là on pourra même pas recevoir
les élèves et et au-delà des des écoles
des administrations des habitations il
faut aussi penser à l'économie il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui dépendent du
gaz et s'il y a des coupures de gaz ça
mettra des des Safra du chômage partiel
ou des faillites et même s'il y a pas de
coupure l'augmentation du prix du gaz et
de l'électricité et aussi du carburant
ça met en difficulté le tissu économique
dans son entièreté et donc ça peut
provoquer des une crise une récession du
chômage et en Allemagne les parties sont
plus dépendants que nous mais les années
sont vraiment ils ont fait le choix
écologique donc pratiquement plus de
centrales nucléaires et ils se
retrouvent catastrophique encore plus
dans la merde que nous les Allemands
c'est vraiment le c'est catastrophique
ce qui se passe en Allemagne aussi parce
que Macron a inauguré des éoliennes
c'est comme c'est intermittent ça oblige
à construire les centres le gaz c'est
pas les compenser et donc ça nous rend
dépendant du gaz qui est vraiment pas la
bonne idée en ce moment c'est c'est
alors aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir des coupures d'électricité je vois
beaucoup d'entreprises qui reçoivent des
mails je vous le dis qui est des mails
qui leur dit entre 15 octobre et le 15
mars il risque d'y avoir des coupures
d'électricité on vous préviendra mais
commencer il y a des gens qui commencent
à avoir comment ça a essayé de de
prendre des et comment on peut faire
parce qu'il paraît qu'il y a des
entreprises qui commencent à prendre des
groupes électrogènes tout ça alors il y
a les groupes électrogène mais ce qui
peut se passer en fait et EDF à essayer
les accords avec les grands entreprises
consommatrices c'est que en cas de
manque d'électricité
il demandera aux entreprises très
consommatrices comme les parents la
fabrication d'aluminium c'est très
consommateur il donnera d'arrêter leur
production pour éviter de faire des
coupures d'électricité parce que ça ça
c'est le vrai risque parce que c'est des
choses qui se passent dans les pays en
difficulté consomme le plus des
tristesse qu'il y aura pas par exemple
des particuliers qui consomment beaucoup
d'électricité ou ils vont leur dire il
faut il faut voir quand on peut faire
alors est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
contrôles on a découvert à l'occasion
que la loi la loi imposait enfin on
pouvait pas chauffer trop non plus sinon
ça pouvait être répréhensible est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des gens qui vont
contrôler avec un petit truc à farouche
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit moi il paraît
qu'il pourrait peut-être avoir des
contrôles de personnes qui viennent chez
vous qui disent ah bah là il y a trop de
chauffage il y a trop d'électricité
frérot il voit si tu as une note
d'électricité élevée ils vont dire il
faut y aller mollo la température aussi
exactement c'est tout simple à contrôler
au contraire vous puissiez dans un
violon mais faut pas être on nous
prépare au pire bien sûr vous avez le
président de la République le ministre
de l'économie qui met des col roulés
je regardais ce weekend France
Télévisions ils ont fait une très longue
explication de la météo de l'électricité
là on va avoir ça veut dire c'est l'état
donc forcément ils ont des impôts ça
veut dire que ça arrive total énergie
qui fait des restos qui veut faire des
restos tournent au bon consommateur
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en creux que
les mauvais consommateurs on va les
sanctionner donc faut pas être naïf on
prépare un panel de sanctions et de
privation potentielle d'électricité réel
stevaire la situation pour moi elle est
très inquiétante les primes pour les
pour les consommateurs
les primes c'est honteux ils veulent
donner des primes de 150 euros au bon
consommateur au mauvais consommateur
c'est à dire celui qui est à 19 degrés
on lui donne une prime celui qui était
déjà à 19 de celui qui traîne le cul
il a pas de prime celui qui a pas le
moment de chauffer
de 3 millions de gens qui ont des
compteurs Linky à qui veulent donner des
plus de 150 euros c'est à dire que moi
qui chauffe depuis 6 ans à 19 degrés
j'ai pas de prime tout le mec qui a fait
le chemin bien celui qui a chauffé à 24
degrés lui va avoir une prime mais celui
qui a pas d'oseille qui peut pas ce qui
peut pas se chauffer lui il a pas la
prime c'est le truc le plus c'est
l'injustice total ce truc là faites pas
faut pas le faire c'est le moment ça
marche c'est débile c'est une blague
quoi je peux vous la raconter mais bon
alors ça se passe dans un avion c'est un
couple c'est un couple qui est dans un
avion et voilà c'est un pôle de nuit et
donc ils disent ils sont à côté ils font
vas-y je suis très envie là et tout mais
non mais non mais non on peut pas on
peut pas et tout tu vois bien que on
peut pas on peut pas faire ça dans
l'avion dit mais si mais si tu vois bien
que tout le monde dort
vas-y bah demande un stylo et tu vas
voir si tout le monde dort ou pas
est-ce que quelqu'un a un stylo s'il
vous plaît
en allant personne ne bouge donc là
toute la nuit
c'est un truc de
foule est presque arrivé donc là il
allume les lumières et là il y a une
vieille dame qui comme ça croqueville
dans l'avion qui est très très froid et
il y a l'hôtesse qui dit Madame ça va le
faire je suis quand même très très froid
pendant la nuit on dit pourquoi vous
avez pas demandé une couverture elle va
sûrement pas il y en a un qui a demandé
si loin
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que Patrick alors
honteux 53%
utile 46% ces dernières questions
Philippe parce qu'il faut s'attendre au
pire comme elle a dit Gilles Verdez
c'est un autre possible il faut mais
c'est un lieu tout à fait possible
malheureusement donc
si l'hiver rigoureux on risque vraiment
d'avoir des coupures voilà ça va
dépendre de la température et ça va
dépendre aussi du fait que les réacteurs
nucléaires se remettent en marche c'est
prévu mais est-ce que le calendrier
c'est pas sûr non parce que ouais
qu'il a arrêté décidément c'est la
pression exactement moi je suis pour
l'écologie à fond mais attention est-ce
que vous êtes les questions qu'il faut
se poser est-ce que l'économie est plus
importante que l'écologie vaut toujours
à trouver le juste milieu et là par
exemple les Allemands n'ont pas trouvé
nous Hollande il s'est fait brouiller le
pauvre à mon avis les écoliers qui sont
dû lui donner des des des des grains de
maïs ou je sais pas quoi voilà
on a continué la police
il sera pas la première fois il était
pas là ils sont en train d'acheter des
croissants ce jour-là merci Philippe il
y a d'abord été avec merci beaucoup